[Musique]
he has montplaisir bonjour vous avez 71
ans vous êtes membre de la république en
marche vous briguez votre troisième
mandat de maire
qu'est ce qui vous pousse à vous
présenter une troisième fois
qu'est ce qui vous motive mesdames et
messieurs les auditeurs et
téléspectateurs
monsieur livory bonjour oui je brigue
mon troisième mandat
parce que je souhaite terminer ce que
j'ai entrepris il y a de cela
12 ans bientôt et qui est aux
trois-quarts fait qu'ils demandent que a
pour moi je veux terminer mais
évidemment sachant que je le termine
pour que d'autres puissent continuer ce
que j'ai entrepris et qui finalement l'a
jamais de fin quand on prévoit des
choses il ya les autres continuent ça
veut dire quoi que vous pensez déjà la
relève que ce sable que 2020 pourrait
être votre dernier mandat
gelli quand on est une personne
responsable
on fait des choses avec responsabilité
quand on a 71 ans et qu'on sait qu'on
terminera mandat à 60 18 ans si on est
réélu je pense que il faut avoir
l'intelligence de comprendre qu'il
faudra prévoir de laisser la place et je
tiens à vous dire que je sais ce que je
fais mes collègues amis et moi même nous
savons ce que nous faisons et si nous
sommes réélus si je suis de nous voir à
la mairie
nous ferons en sorte de ne pas laisser
les choses
n'importe comment les pilotes in et puis
le train décideront si ce qu'on propose
tient la route mais nous avons nous déjà
notre idée sur la suite ce sera ce sera
une femme ce sera un homme libre il vous
avez laissé moi le souhait de laisser la
surprise
je sais que les gens seront heureux
alors vous êtes attaqués par vos
adversaires d'une part elie car unique
ici même dans cette émission vous a mis
en cause dans une affaire de passation
de marchés il a clairement indiqué que
vous auriez favorisé une entreprise dans
laquelle vous auriez départ qu'en est il
bailly l'enec je vais pas perdre de
temps le peu de temps qui m'est imparti
pour m'exprimer ici aujourd'hui pour
répondre à ça je vous dirais simplement
que il fait ce qu'il veut c'est son
droit
et comment je fais ce que je veux il m'a
insulté il m'a incriminés il a mis mon
honneur en cause
je porte plainte que j'ai porté plainte
et je demanderai des dommages-intérêts
monsieur carbonique parce que ça fait
plusieurs fois maintenant qu'il le fait
et puis à un moment il faut savoir dire
aux gens ça suffit assez c'est assez
ja c'est alors vous êtes aussi attaqué
sur les finances de la commune
votre gestion a été épinglée par la
chambre régionale des comptes en comptes
administratifs de 2018 un déficit de
plus de quatre millions cinq cent mille
euros
il s'agit du dernier avis de la crc daté
du 15 octobre
parrish mois au mois de novembre
cependant la crc souligne dans ses
conclusions que je cite les mesures
prises dans le budget 2010 9 sont
suffisantes pour permettre le retour à
l'équilibré budgétaire au 31 décembre
fin de citation c'est un bon point de la
crc c'est un très bon point parce qu'il
nous permet en plus de baisser les
impôts de la commune ça devrait être la
seule commune avait de l'avancé vous
avez dû augmenter les impôts pour rubin
en avait on avait accepté à contrecoeur
l'année dernière une petite augmentation
et ça faisait cinq ans six ans qu'on
essayait de nous l'imposer
nous avions refusé nous sommes partis
avec un déficit effectivement de l'ordre
de près de 4 millions d'euros et nous
avons terminé l'année avec normalement
dans notre budget un excédent de qui est
de 750 mille euros que nous avons
réparti pour le hauteur de 700 mille
euros sur le budget d'investissement qui
lui est en déficit et 50000 euros en
excédent sur le budget de fonctionnement
d'où le fait que la crc nous félicitent
ce qu'elle n'a pas de manquer de faire
pendant tous les sept années où nous
avons régulièrement ramener le déficit
et où tous les ans nous faisait
remarquer qu'elle apprécie à la qualité
de notre
vas y alors quels seront les grands axes
de votre programme ben écoute et
terminer ce que nous avons entrepris
nous avons finalement gagné un procès au
bout de onze ans pour récupérer un
terrain qui était vendu 700 mille euros
et pour lequel la commune allait faire
sept cent mille euros de travaux pour
l'acheteur c'est à dire qu'on donnait un
terrain 700000 euros à quelqu'un là
aujourd'hui on a complètement récupéré
nous sommes en train de signer les
promesses de ventes nous avons les la
caserne des pompiers qui est en
construction sur ce terrain
cette caserne des pompiers la commune
offre le terrain la valeur de ce qui est
offert et de 800000 euros sachant que le
terrain dans son ensemble est vendu 200
euros du mètre carré travaux effectués
et 230 euros du mètre carré pour une
certaine partie qui appartient heures le
centre commercial
c'est à dire que l'ensemble du terrain
est vendu 10 millions d'euros sur les
dix millions d'euros
il ya huit mille huit cent mille euros
de terrain offert à aux pompiers
il ya donc 909 millions 200 mille euros
qui seront encaissés par la commune et
sur les 9 million deux cent mille euros
il ya 4 million deux cent mille euros de
travaux à payer donc la commune va
vendre 5 millions d'euros un terrain
total faisait cadeau à un monsieur de
quinze pilotes
bref mon plaisir je vous remercie